Tenemos esta balanza en equilibrio como puedes ver,
y la pregunta que tenemos es acerca de esta
masa misteriosa, la azul que está aquí
y también tenemos muchas masas de 1 kg, éstas
que están aquí, todas son iguales.
Y la pregunta que te quiero hacer es,
¿qué podríamos hacer para saber el valor
de esta masa misteriosa?
Ya sea quitar o poner cosas de un lado o del
otro o ¿realmente podremos saberlo?
Esto es pensar en qué podemos hacer en todo
lo que podamos hacer para encontrar el valor
de esta masa misteriosa y te voy a dar algunos
segundos para pensar en esto.
Pues para saber el valor de esta masa misteriosa,
lo que tendríamos que hacer es dejarla sola
de este lado de la balanza, si quitamos estos
3 que están del lado izquierdo pues no es
suficiente, algo más tenemos que hacer, al
quitar estos 3 del lado izquierdo entonces
el lado izquierdo de la balanza será más
ligero e irá para arriba y el lado izquierdo
será más pesado y bajará.
Y esto solo revelaría que el lado izquierdo
es más ligero que el lado derecho,
no nos daría más información, no nos diría cual
es el valor de la masa misteriosa.
si lo que buscamos es mantener la balanza
en equilibrio, entonces tendremos que quitar
la misma cantidad de masa del lado izquierdo
y del lado derecho para mantener el equilibrio,
así que voy a quitar 3 de este lado izquierdo...
a ver... mejor voy a cambiar por el borrador...
y al quitarlos, la masa total del lado izquierdo
es menor que la del lado derecho,
si lo que queremos es conservar el equilibrio entonces
tendremos que quitar 3 de ambos lados.
Si iniciamos con una balanza en equilibrio
y quitamos 3 de ambos lados,
conservaremos el equilibrio.
Y al hacer esto, podremos saber cual es el
valor de la masa del lado izquierdo,
porque será igual a lo que quedó del lado derecho.
Así que contemos lo que quedó,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
y si cada uno de ellos tiene un valor de 1
kg, entonces la masa de este objeto es igual
a 7 kg, esto vale 7.